hi I'm Tom Cech and I've been asked to
talk about my favorite experiment why
did I pick this particular experiment
well it was one that I did with my own
hands and there's something special
about discovering something through your
own work in the lab that as much as I
enjoy working with students and
postdoctoral fellows and exalt over
their discoveries something special
about being able to make a discovery by
yourself this came when we were looking
at initially the transcription of large
ribosomal RNA precursor in a single
celled pond animal tetrahymena
thermophilus the gene that we were
looking at made an RNA that was
interrupted by a stretch of non-coding
sequence called an intron and at this
time RNA splicing had been discovered a
few years earlier but people knew very
little about the mechanism by which an
intron containing RNA would be spliced
to rejoin these two flanking sequences
called exons and release that intron RNA
now we had found in our studies of
transcription of this gene that the RNA
splicing was taking place outside of the
cell in vitro with with our purified
extracted RNA so this seemed to be an
opportunity for us to investigate the
mechanism of RNA splicing initially this
splicing reaction was taking place in
the same cocktail of small molecules
that were necessary for transcription so
I decided it would be useful to see
which of those small molecules is really
required not for the transcriptions part
but for the RNA splicing so I
added them I subtracted them one at a
time from the transcription cocktail I
added them back and I found that there
were only two small molecules that were
required one was a simple salt magnesium
chloride and the other was one of the
precursors of RNA itself guanosine
triphosphate a lot of specificity here G
was required a wouldn't do it C wouldn't
do it you wouldn't do it it had to be
guanosine and this seemed unusual it
seemed interesting but I didn't really
know what to make of it until someone
else in the laboratory art Zog was
sequencing the end of the intron after
it was exciting and he found that the
sequence of the cut-out RNA started with
a guanosine residue which is one of the
four nucleotides of RNA we didn't think
much of it until we found out from Joe
Gauls laboratory at Yale University that
they had sequenced the gene that encodes
this RNA and that they were adamant that
there was no guanine present near that
exon intron boundary the rest of our
sequences agreed between the two
laboratories and so here we had a
situation where it looked like maybe
there was a guanine that wasn't encoded
by the DNA that was added to the end of
the intron and at the same time we had
this evidence from my earlier work that
G was a required ingredient in the
splicing reaction so maybe these two
observations were related to each other
although the idea that one could just
add guanosine triphosphate to purified
RNA and expect any chemical reaction any
cutting and joining reaction to take
place seemed unprecedented and really
quite far-fetched so at the time
I did this reaction rather this
experiment rather quietly I didn't tell
any of the graduate students what I was
doing I didn't want to look foolish if
this reaction failed as it was probably
destined to do when I added in one tube
radio labeled gtp - the purified
precursor RNA and in other tubes the
other nucleotides finally in the midst
of my teaching schedule had an
opportunity to run the gel to look at
the splicing products and lo and behold
only in the lane where I had added the
radio labeled gtp was there a radio
labeled are in a band the exact size of
the intervening sequence so I ran back
to my office to try to get a little bit
of peace and quiet to try to draw out
what must be happening in terms of a
splicing mechanism and what I quickly
came up with was that this guanine that
was added during the splicing reaction
was being joined to the five prime end
of the intron so it looked like it was
attacking the splice site phosphate and
forming a new oxygen phosphorous bond
that hadn't been there before now if
that happened that would explain how the
gtp would be covalently bound to the end
of the intron but what would happen with
the other product of this reaction well
the five prime exon would then have to
be released with a hydroxyl group at its
three prime and and exactly the same
kind of a chemical step if it occurred
now between this exon and the downstream
splice site would result in ligation of
the exons
and release of the intron RNA with this
diagnostic guanosine at its at its five
prime an and so I thought well as any
was this even chemically reasonable so
fortunately I had an organic chemistry
textbook
within reach pulled it out it did not
disguise
this sort of reaction with phosphate
esters but with esters of carbon this
was simply a transesterification
reaction so what was happening so there
was precedent for this sort of reaction
you start out with one ester linkage in
this case a phosphodiester linkage and
you now using the hydroxyl group of the
ribose sugar of guanosine as a
nucleophile attack at this site
it's a also called an sn2 reaction as
you've probably studied in your organic
chemistry class and this swapping of
partners in this ester linkage turned
out to be the key mechanism of RNA
splicing so although it was exciting to
have this mechanistic information about
RNA splicing the question of the
catalyst that was allowing all of this
to happen
eluded us for another year we were
assuming that there had to be a protein
enzyme that was responsible for a
reaction that took place with this
incredible specificity after all in this
long RNA there was only one site that
was being chosen as in splice site there
was also specificity with respect to
guanosine relative to the other
nucleotides and the reaction was speeded
up many billions of fold faster than a
spontaneous phospho transesterification
reaction would be predicted to occur so
if all biological catalysts are protein
enzymes where was the protein and we
spent a lot of time looking for protein
contaminants in our pure RNA preparation
finally out of a lack of being able to
identify any we switched around the
hypothesis and said maybe it's just the
RNA that is folding up to form the
catalytic center for this reaction to
test that idea we were able to make an
artificial transcript that had never
seen the inside of a tetrahymena cell
and when we added guanosine triphosphate
to that artificial RNA the addition
of G to the end of the intron and the
RNA splicing that ensued convinced us
that it was time to announce that RNA
could be an enzyme that RNA had
catalytic activity this turned out to be
the experiment or the set of experiments
that resulted in the nobel prize in
chemistry eight years later but I think
it's important to understand that at the
time we were not driven by the
possibility of getting awards or
recognition it was simple curiosity
about how does RNA splicing occur and
how could this reaction even be
occurring with pure RNA that was driving
us in the laboratory and giving us so
much satisfaction
you